I could just give you answers to this I
give you methods and just show you right
from the outset but when I work it's the
first time and I was just having some
explaining to me I know oh well here is
what you do
I learnt it but I didn't understand why
and it was very frustrating to me
because I was like why would you do that
what makes you think that so I'm
actually going to lead you through a bit
of a scenic route as it were
scenic is a bit of a very fancy way of
saying I'm going to lead you through
some mistakes some ways to not do this
so you understand when we get the way
you do do it oh of course you have to do
it because I remember what happened when
we tried the other ways and it sucked
okay
good morning so have a look at this with
me and we have looked at partial
fractions for a little bit now and the
idea is not that complicated
you have a look at your denominator what
you do with the denominator yeah once
you've got to factorize which I have
given it to you in a factorize small
already once it is factorize you've got
like say one two or maybe three factors
factors or the denominator and you say
come in give me you say okay well I am
going to I put the side then the partial
fractions I can break it up into our
something over one factor plus something
over another factor plus however many
times you do it for how many factors you
have does that make sense so when you
have a look like something like this it
is not unreasonable to assume I can take
a similar approach so let's see what
happens I get let's try it let's let
this alright all right now let's try and
take a similar approach to how we okay
so I've got one that I've got two so
that means I'm going to suggest that
there will be partial fractions right
here's my first one
in my second one now like I said some of
you have encountered this before we'll
look at this and say that's not what
you're supposed to do okay I would
challenge you to say well why why is it
that this can you explain an oh I will
get to an explanation I just want you to
have a turning around your head if you
know that this is wrong
the real question is why is it wrong
okay let's see what happens because this
is the way that maths is born you give
something a go what do we usually do at
this point
once I've written down the first
impression what do I have to do yeah I
need you to combine so that I've gotten
denominators the same
and then I can compare numerous let's go
ahead let's do that so I'm going to get
this to be like so
and at this point I have a choice you
might remember because I've now got my
numerator upside down oh good come on
denominators the same I could do
something like say let X equal 2 once I
can page the numerators
that'll make it to term disappear I
explain why I don't think that's the
best math but it still worked textbooks
cuter and if it sort of doesn't make
sense if you can order denominator they
watch I could do that I'm gonna go back
with my normal method and compare the
coefficients what I need to do to
compare coefficients I'm not quite ready
yet yeah I do need to expand and get all
the x squared terms the X terms and the
constant terms okay but that's it let's
just go ahead enough let's see if we can
do it right off the bat how many x
squared terms do you see look carefully
I just see the one it's that guy right
no exquisite going to come for being so
I'm just going to write that down like
so okay the X terms how many X terms you
see I see an ax ax and BX there so I'm
gonna go here factorize that I tell me X
is I've gotten yeah okay and close the
terms yeah there's a minus to it and
there's a to be just so then I don't
have to thinking about the front I'm
gonna write it like so
are you content with that if I got my X
Squared's my X to the ones makes a
little zeroes and there's my denominator
happily sitting it okay they have a look
at this right so because I mentioned
I've got three different terms to
compare one two three I'm going to get
three simultaneous equations out of this
okay
let's see what happens I'm going to
write down I'm gonna compare by
comparison of coefficients
and then I'm going to go X Squared's x
ones X naught okay so how many x squared
terms that I can have a left ear top
four of them so how many do I have on
the right hand side okay huh that
doesn't usually happen that's okay once
you see let's just proceed how many X
terms might have left hand side 0 so 0
equals a plus B and then I say ok well
my constant term now 8 now I've got to
be minus 2a yep okay 1 2 3
okay now so far I just done the normal
process that I've gone through before
but now I've run into a problem haven't
I
yes that look on your face is exactly
the look you stood out in your face
what's gone wrong how can you tell
something has gone wrong first from my
oh no this is like we notice this like
what am I getting three equations just
solve for two variables this is not just
weird this is a problem because the
problem flows out of that of course is
where you just start trying to solve
them right you don't have to solve for B
it's right there so what does that tell
you about a must be negative four so you
ain't hot a second so now I have some
values for a and B already so then you
look to the third equation and you say
oh wait a second 2 times negative 4
right
yes oh yeah of course
this is that's that so you've got eight
and then you've got minus negative eight
you've got sixteen on this right-hand
side oh okay so problem number one you
might even like to write these down
problem one is I have too many equations
for two favorite few variables we
usually identify this problem in the
reverse direction we're like oh I've got
lots of variables to solve for unnoticed
but I don't have enough equations don't
have enough information to solve but
here I have the opposite problem right
second problem is that it doesn't work
precisely because of that reason well I
did just have two of the equations any
two of these would be okay right they'd
have a solution the reason why is
because any pair of straight line
right because that's what these are so
long as they're not parallel they'll
always have a solution somewhere but
when you go for three no guarantees
they're not all concurrent there won't
be a solution there's a third problem
which kind of explains why we ended up
with this problem in the first place
right because remember we wrote this
down and we said huh that's a bit
unusual that doesn't usually happen can
anyone see where it comes from it's one
of the lines early that we wrote down
kinda okay that you're actually going
towards the answer already but that
still doesn't explain why it's wrong I
will get to that answer let me try to
show you what's sort of weird about this
right the first thing that I noticed I
started writing down in simultaneous
equations it is hey look beat is just
sitting there it doesn't care what the
other new printer release do you notice
that and the reason why is because I
wrote this down who are there's only one
X where there's only one expression
where is it come from and the answer is
it's come from this tiny person to a
common denominator so it's come from
here in other words this area is
contributing nothing to be x squared
that's wrong it shouldn't these two are
supposed to interact with each other
that's the point of these equations
right what we got is too simple it's too
simple this should be some x squared
term appearing over here as well and
then you'll get a balance here and then
it was solved so in order to get an x
squared term out of the other thing how
am I going to do this okay so this is
approach number one and it didn't work
just by trying the previous way I'm
gonna try another approach so this was
uh this is no one
and this is the reason why
mathematicians have bleep it's not
because we just decided most of the time
it's because we tried the other things
and it's like we could end up with self
inconsistencies it's contradictory so
here comes number two okay now I'm just
going to try this just for the sake of
giving it a go
what we're going to run into some
similar problems okay it all started
with our original assumption let's try a
different one
okay if I let and I promise this one
will not take as long as the previous
one to work out that there was a problem
okay now I'm going to introduce a
different pair of partial fractions okay
do you remember before when you have the
degree of the top and the bottom
matching you're like oh well you can't
do it in this way so we add one do you
remember that so I can just make sure
just a different kind of identity please
the idea I'm gonna try I'm gonna leave
this as a and instead I want an extra I
want like terms of higher powers to
appear so I'm gonna have a high power in
here I'm gonna call this be X plus C
okay now the reason why I'm trying this
is because if I introduce this then when
I multiply through by here I'll get an x
squared term maybe that will be useful
to me okay now this is all I need to
write to show that this is not going to
work right like I'm in a second I'm
gonna show you the third approach which
will work right but why doesn't the
second approach work what's wrong yeah
okay now there's no probably introduced
in terms of don't exist you just want to
know for example when I did this right
and when we do it sometimes
I've got no X terms but that's okay
that's that sometimes forms an important
part of you simultaneous equations
itself that's not initiative but when
you look here how would you solve this X
cubed problem well the X cubed is going
to come from B right do you see that
you're gonna get B X cubed so the only
way to solve it is to make B equal to 0
but if you do that you're in exactly the
same boat that you started with before
you've just labeled it with a different
level right so this solution is
no better than the one I tried before so
I need a different way he comes down the
trick